my idea of a writer is not a
first-person a social person a person
who expresses himself in society or in
the community but a person who for this
thread this or that reason tragically
ourselves over with joy who lives the
community the society the group the
tribe the nation or the grill that he or
she belongs and first with some sort of
an instinct that he doesn't want to
understand goes to a room and rights
there there he explores his perhaps
first in the inner depths of his soul
but then comes out with something new
which will address to all humanity
because the essential idea being that we
are all we have the same kind of mine
you